We have presented
the complete solution
to the liner least mean squares
estimation problem, when
we want to estimate a certain
unknown random variable
on the basis of a
different random variable X
that we get to observe.
But what if we have
multiple observations?
What would be the analogous
formulation of the problem?
Here's the idea.
Once more, we restrict
ourselves to estimators
that are linear functions of
the data, linear functions
of the observations
that we have.
And then we pose the
problem of finding the best
choices of these coefficients
a1 up to a n and b.
What does it mean to
find the best choices?
It means that if we
fix certain choices,
we obtain an estimator,
we look at the difference
between the estimator
and the quantity
we're trying to estimate,
take the square,
and then take the expectation.
So once more, we're looking
at the mean squared error
of our estimator and we try to
make it as small as possible.
So this is a well-defined
optimization problem.
We have a quantity, which is a
function of certain parameters.
And we wish to find the
choices for those parameters,
or those coefficients,
that will make
this quantity as
small as possible.
One first comment is
similar to the case
where we had a single
measurement [and]
is the following.
If it turns out that the
conditional expectation
of Theta given all
of the data that we
have is linear in X, if it is
of this form, then what happens?
We know that this is the
best possible estimator.
If it is also linear, then
it is the best estimator
within the class of
linear estimators as well
and, therefore, the linear
least mean squares estimator
is the same as the general
least mean squares estimator.
So if for some problems it
turns out that this is linear,
then we automatically also have
the optimal linear estimator.
And this is going to
be the case, once more,
for certain normal problems with
a linear structure of the type
that we have studied earlier.
Now, let us look
into what it takes
to carry out this optimization.
If we had a single
observation, then we
have seen a closed form formula,
a fairly simple formula,
that tells us what the
coefficients should be.
For the more general
case, formulas
would not be as
simple, but we can
make the following observations.
If you take this
expression and expand it,
it's going to have
a bunch of terms.
For example, it's going to have
a term of the form a1 squared
times the expected
value of X1 squared.
It's going to have a term
such as twice a1, a2 times
the expected value of X1, X2.
And then there's going to be
many more terms to some of them
will also involve products
of Theta with this.
So we might see that we have
a term of the form a1 expected
value of X1 Theta.
And then, there's going to
be many, many more terms.
What's the important
thing to notice?
That this expression as a
function of the coefficient
involves terms
either of this kind
or of this kind,
or of that kind,
first-order or
second-order terms.
To minimize this
expression, we're
going to take the derivative
of this and set it equal to 0.
When you take the derivative
of a function that
involves only quadratic
and linear terms,
you get something that's
linear in the coefficients.
The conclusion out of
all this discussion
is that when you actually go
and carry out this minimization
by setting derivatives
to zero, what you
will end up doing is solving
a system of linear equations
in the coefficients that
you're trying to determine.
And why is this interesting?
Well, it is because
if you actually
want to carry out
this minimization,
all you need to do is to solve
a linear system, which is easily
done on a computer.
The next observation is
that this expression only
involves expectations
of various terms
that are second order in the
random variables involved.
So it involves the expected
value of X1 squared,
it involves this term,
which has something
to do with the
covariance of X1 and X2.
This term that has something
to do with the covariance of X1
with Theta.
But these are the only terms out
of the distribution of the X's
and of Theta that will matter.
So similar to the case where
we had a single observation,
in order to solve
this problem, we
do not need to know the
complete distribution of the X's
and of Theta.
It is enough to know
all of the means,
variances, and covariances
of the random variables
that are involved.
And once more, this
makes this approach
to estimation a practical
one, because we do not
need to model in complete
detail the distribution
of the different
random variables.
Finally, if we do not have just
one unknown random variable,
but we have multiple
random variables that we
want to estimate,
what should we do?
Well, this is pretty simple.
You just apply this
estimation methodology
to each one of the unknown
random variables separately.
To conclude, this linear
estimation methodology
applies also to the case where
you have multiple observations.
You need to solve a certain
computational problem in order
to find the structure of
the best linear estimator,
but it is not a very difficult
computational problem,
because all that it
involves is to minimize
a quadratic function
of the coefficients
that you are trying
to determine.
And this leads us
to having to solve
a system of linear equations.
For all these reasons,
linear estimation,
or estimation using linear
estimators, is quite practical.